hey guys it is top five time which means
if you stick with me for the next couple
of minutes you'll hear five of the cool
things that happen in gaming this week
let's get stuck into it
first off the resident evil revelations
2 info has been rolling in the latest of
which is around an announcement that the
game will be released episodically
similar to the format of tell tales
walking dead series revelations 2 will
be composed of four main chapters to be
released as individual episodes once a
week the complete season will run you 25
bucks or you can buy them individually
for six dollars apiece if you're real
good at math you probably figured out
that the bundle is going to cost you an
extra dollar that doll will be buying
you additional game content to be
announced later on there will eventually
also be a disc based version featuring
all the available content plus some more
extra content for 40 bucks to cater to
you content buffs ESPN has come out to
say the eSports are not a real sport and
expectedly that is kind of pissed off
fans major mobos ESPN's president has
said League of Legends and dota 2 aren't
comparable to football or basketball he
explained it's not a sport it's a
competition Chaz's the competition's
checkers is a competition mostly I'm
interested in doing real sports his
comments were made in response to
Amazon's acquisition of twitch and
interestingly fly in the face of the
fact that the finals of last month's 11
million dollars 0 to 2 tournaments the
International and on espn3 the network's
online branch destiny came out this week
which has everybody buzzing and calling
in sick for work but just how long does
the campaign take for you to complete
here at gamespot we take our jobs very
seriously and so we powered through the
campaign to tell you that it takes about
16 hours to get through although all our
planet hopping and robots shooting
didn't include completing bounties or
spending time doing extra Vanguard and
strike missions or even looking into any
of the postgame stuff so there certainly
is more game left to play to check out
the full list of stuff you can do
outside of the main campaign check out
our story on site
to get the most out of your Destiny's
playthrough minecraft creator mojang
mainly bought out by Microsoft according
to a report from The Wall Street Journal
inside sources have suggested that the
deal could go through as early as this
week and may run Microsoft more than 2
billion just last year movie and
co-founder calm Manny said that a buyout
would be unlikely so if they already
have more money than they need if
Microsoft did buy the block you world
building game though sources have told
Bloomberg that the type of existence on
PlayStation would not be in jeopardy
we'll give you more info on this one as
it unravels and my favorite thing that
happened this week was Microsoft's
trying to find a workaround to the fact
that they were allowed to advertise
destiny to xbox one in the UK the reason
for that is due to an agreement between
Activision and Sony nonetheless somebody
in Microsoft's UK team must have had a
brainwave that although they weren't
allowed to advertise destiny the game
they could advertise destiny the
fragrance and so although you can't
actually buy and sample the sweet scent
of destiny if you headed over to destiny
fragrance calm you'd find an explanation
of the game that has since been removed
and replaced with a short note about the
xbox one offers available at the moment
let me know what your favorite story was
from this week and if you thought the
destiny fragrance were hilarious or
stupid as for what's on site this week
you can watch our now playing episode
featuring super smash brothers for 3d
yes check out our sims 4 review to find
out what's what in the new game or see
the final boss battle in destiny if
you're so inclined those are all the
good things I want to tell you about
this week as always be sure to have
yourself an awesome weekend and I will
catch you again on Monday